with the clock ticking towards the July
deadline for annexation the UN
secretary-general made his position to
the Security Council extremely clear if
implemented annexation would constitute
the most serious violation of
international law grievously harm the
prospect of a two-state solution and
advocate the possibility is a very new
all of negotiations I call on these very
government's to abandon its annexation
class Palestinian foreign minister riad
al-maliki says the Israel of Benjamin
Netanyahu doesn't believe it's bound by
international norms or laws Israel
things as has been its experience so far
that it will not be fined or arrested it
believes that Security Council
resolutions are binding for others
international courts have jurisdictions
over others sanctions are for others
Israel's ambassador Danny's are known
went back in history to justify
annexation ever since Moses led the
people of Israel out of Egypt through
the Sinai desert and to the Land of
Israel returning to the land that God
had promised a gram Jews have believed
in exercise sovereignty in the promised
land but the vast majority 14 out of 15
members of the Security Council are
following more recent history the
council's own resolutions when Israel
took East Jerusalem the West Bank and
Gaza in the 1967 war the Security
Council declared in numerous subsequent
resolutions that these were occupied
territories since then large parts of
this Palestinian land has been taken
over by Israeli settlers but this is the
first time in 52 years that Israel has
come close to declaring sovereignty and
taking permanent political control it
has never been our intent to impose a
solution the only country that could
stop it it's close ally the US and
Kelly Kraft said little on the issue of
annexation but speaking at the same time
as her in Washington DC her boss the US
Secretary of State was clearer decisions
about Israeli annexed in extending
sovereignty in other places or decisions
for some might see that as a green light
for Israel certainly Israel is now in
the driving seat it's not clear if it
will actually carry out annexation and
if it does when it will take place and
how much of the West Bank will be
annexed James BAE's al Jazeera at the
United Nations